wow
ciao a tutti
solite stesse oggi challenge prova a non
rilassarti gialle che gli hanno già
fatto una legge del genere tempo fa
proviamo fatta da sola stanza vitale e
tira piaciuta tantissimo belleri
chiedete sempre quindi dobbiamo cercare
di guardare questa serie di video senza
rilassarci vediamo che effetto fanno
questo video perché sono dei video un
uomo molto rilassanti ovviamente
includono anche tanti slyvco dei suoni
bellissime franca si prendete il vostro
the passati neo pop corn e camomilla
mentre se li comodi mettetevi le cuffie
video sotto schermo e iniziamo subito
laziale che è pigmento con lo slime il
pigmento fa un effetto bellissimo
parlato aveva fatto a forma di cuore
quella come cambia il colore
[Musica]
verdi un lo dico io pure blu
partiamo dall'inizio ad alberto adesso
di bersagli girare uscirà fuori verde si
verde ma come ha fatto sta proprio sia
difficile fare non voltiamo lo dico
sentissimo non ti devi restare
miorilassante sono agitato famosi si
difende con un microfono ricordano che
fa mangiandolo ma questa collegata
perrotta che è successo
che belle
ma questo congelato racconto il morbido
accarino la faccio adesso comincio a
tutti sia qualcosa c'è qualcosa sotto
questa bella si gioca a voi rilassa
quello va a meno veramente cosa questi
fare le loro scelte
wow che figo come li schiaccia liguri
scherzetti adesso ma io voglio
commentare tutte belle
questa cosa è stupendo sta mettendo tipo
del del colore acrilico forse è stupendo
ma che supportino infine
bello colpi le rose line sono ora
[Musica]
mi fido poi di schiacciarle tutte ma
come diventa poi mischiato 600 che
l'impasto della pasta per un ristoro
fontana per quante fishbowl questo fa
dei sogni pozzetti sarò il pigmento
tanto anche il plus 8 suoni sono super
inverno senza mi sto rilassando questo
tornare un giorno al miur il mio amore
che non ho ben capito cos'è avvenuto tra
una bellissima fanno farli questi
bellissimo e tipo congelato cosa no
congelato aguri l'amour
la luna rossa l'anguria gialla ancora le
palline sono fatte di plastilina ford
sempre notato uguali perfetto la voglia
scherza e si è molto rilassante chris
nolan parlando perché mi spiego le
barchette
ciao stupendo bello sì vengo un remo
come diventa grigio è bello questo club
topolino mentre stiamo ancora un furto
uno spettacolo fantastico fanese
bellissimo si colori stupendo
ma perche e questa volta non è mai un
pompeo addio qua c'è anche un brano
stranissimo la bandiera americana a
farne parte stai
[Musica]
poi dopo li tolgono ci mettono un altro
slime dentro no non penso sia questo
vedi che lo tagliano c'è un altro non
altro tanto vediamo dove rivista questa
comoda in quelli presidente è sempre lo
stesso ora mischiato che ho finito
oddio quale ho visto proprio che sarà un
player slam sopra talmente clio
wow
non volevamo vedere tutto lo slime ecco
uno zio questa è una torta che strano
preferisco consumato le mani dentro il
grigio a chiamare che colori di un
termine molto la santa
mettersi da solo è un atto che bello se
le vengono già così questi lo abbiamo
fatto anche noi con andrebbero
bellissimo pensato a fare questa cosa
mattia è un cammino dopo però che figo
l'effetto di ottobre un po dei vermi
anche a che scappasse mi ricorda un po i
brufoli di nuovo oddio mi sa che puzza
poi
basta un ottimo tendono stava vivendo si
alza sempre bello questo rilassante caro
amore
[Musica]
sì che il rumore che ha fatto siamo
corti carrozza spugna assurdo pensavo
fosse la neve finta io non devo accordi
per niente siamo rilassati un po troppo
dove stiamo già vivendo gli ottimi non
so per carino se
io no allora ragazzi
fateci sapere cosa vi ha rilassato di
più noi ovviamente ci siamo rilassati
dormire è comunque stato bellissimo
queste cose lasciate shell timestamp
della cosa che vi ha rilassato di più
che magari proviamo riprodurla noi
fateci sapere se avete vinto o se avete
perso e ora vi lasciamo al 34 castellini
su cui cliccare per le nostre altre
challenge video divertenti slime smr
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione